all right let's get to a couple of wacky
things in different ways this memo has
now leaked this is a memo from Donald
Trump's lawyer
um with a plan a six-point plan for how
they wanted to overturn the results of
the 2020 election this memo is
remarkable
but for more than one reason it's
remarkable because of the audacity of
thinking to do this it's also remarkable
because it makes clear to me that they
know this is all Bs they know Trump
didn't actually win and it's also
remarkable because I wonder had someone
even more absurd than Mike Pence uh been
president a vice president at the time
is there a chance not that it would have
actually kept Trump in office but that
it might have led to even more chaos uh
if the vice president had been willing
to at least try some of this stuff so
the international business times
reporting
leaked memo shows how Trump's lawyer
wanted Pence to overturn elections the
leaked memo outlined six steps Pence
could take to declare Trump the winner
of the election the memo included plans
to overthrow the Electoral College votes
from seven states Pence argued the
Constitution did not give him power to
overturn the results this is all
outlined in the book Peril which
explains that conservative lawyer John
Eastman allegedly sent a two-page memo
outlining these steps at the end he
announces that because of the ongoing
disputes in the seven states there are
no electors that can be deemed validly
appointed in those States meaning the
total number of electors appointed is
454. a majority of those appointed would
be 228 and Trump would have 232 of them
now we're going to look at the six point
plan in detail in a moment
some of these details are wild which
includes that the proposal was first
given to Pence on January 4 two days
before the the riot when Trump attempted
to convince the then president the then
vice president that he had the authority
to overturn it you really need to listen
to John he's a respected constitutional
scholar hear him out Trump told Pence
however Pence refused to intervene
saying he doesn't have that Authority
and then this is maybe the craziest
detail on January 6th hours before the
riot Pence told Trump Constitution
doesn't let me do it and that led Trump
to hold their friendship hostage no no
no Trump shouted you don't understand
Mike you can do this I don't want to be
your friend anymore if you don't do this
so let's look at the six point plan okay
step one
Pence presiding over the joint session
or Senate Pro Temp Grassley if Pence
recuses begins to open and count ballots
starting with Alabama without conceding
that the procedure specified by the
Electoral count Act of going through the
states alphabetically is required
when he gets to Arizona he announces he
has multiple slates of electors and so
is going to defer decision until uh on
that until finishing the other states
this would be the first break with the
procedure set out in the act so this is
an idea we talked about before they were
talking about you just send different
electors send send Republican electors
step 3 at the end he announces that
because of the ongoing disputes in seven
states there are no electors that can be
deemed validly appointed in those states
that means the total number of electors
appointed the language of the 12th
Amendment is 454.
uh this reading of the 12th Amendment
has also been Advanced by Harvard law
professor Lawrence tribe a majority of
the electors appointed would therefore
be 228 if you reduce the number of
appointed electors you reduce what it
counts as 50 plus one uh there are at
this point 232 for Trump 222 for Biden
Pence gavels president Trump as
re-elected howls of course from the
Democrats who now claim contrary to
tribe's prior position that 270 is
required so Penn says Fine pursuant to
the 12th Amendment no candidate has
achieved the necessary majority that
sends the matter to the house where the
votes shall be taken by States the
representation from each state having
one vote Republicans currently
controlled 26 State delegations
president Trump is re-elected there as
well
step five one last piece assuming the
Electoral count act process is followed
and upon getting the objections to the
Arizona slates the two houses break into
separate Chambers we should not allow
that the Electoral count act constrained
on debate to control
that would mean that a prior legislature
was determining the rules of the present
one a constitutional No-No so someone
Ted Cruz Rand Paul should demand normal
rules which includes the filibuster that
creates a stalemate and it would give
the state legislatures more time to
weigh in to formally support the
alternate slate of electors if they
haven't already done so
and finally step six the main thing here
is that pens should do this without
asking for permission either from a vote
of the joint session or from the court
let the other side challenge his actions
in court whoa sorry and the zoom just
went crazy let me get resumed in here
uh number six
um let the other side challenge his
actions in court where tribe who
conceded in 2001 the president of the
Senate might be in charge of counting
the votes and others who would press a
lawsuit that these are non-justicerable
justiceable political questions thrown
back at them
um okay yeah anyway step six is like so
far out there that it's not even even as
relevant although this is completely
absurd and ludicrous
imagine if Donald Trump had had someone
as his vice president willing to try
like Pence just said I'm not even gonna
I'm not even gonna try because I can't
do it
I still believe it would not have
succeeded but it would have caused a
hell of a lot of Chaos in the process
and then you know I know these terms are
hyperbolic the terms I'm about to use if
they had pulled off what would have been
a coup
could it have launched a civil war of
sorts like what would actually happen if
this had been attempted and then they
would have used that to say look at how
violent the left is
um and absolutely insane six-step plan I
guess it feels weird to say this but I
guess in some way we should be glad it
was Pence and not someone even crazier
like VP Marjorie Taylor green almost
certainly tries this VP Matt Gates
probably tries this it still fails but
it might cause insane chaos and violence
in so doing
one of our sponsors is steadymd primary
care the easier and more affordable way
to do primary care and they're giving
you 50 off because you are in my
audience you just answer a few questions
steady MD will match you with a licensed
primary care physician that's tailored
to your needs you'll have a one-hour
virtual appointment and start a
meaningful relationship with your new
doctor and from then on your doctor will
be available to you by text phone and
video chat it's not some random doctor
on call your steady MD doctor has a
limited number of patients you get the
attention you deserve and they can help
you with anything your primary care doc
normally would it's very cool how it
works you don't need insurance
it's just 99 bucks a month no other fees
or co-pays for visits take the free quiz
and see which doctor is a perfect fit
for you you'll get 50 off your first
month when you go to steadymd.com Pacman
no risk no long-term commitment the link
is right underneath the video